voici téranteau et si presque tout est
écrit en farci nous sommes au coeur de
la communauté iranienne de Toronto la
plus grande au Canada depuis le début du
soulèvement en Iran les tensions entre
partisans et opposants au régime si son
cristallisés la police a dénombré
plusieurs incidences comme à cette
mosquée qui a été recouverte de
graffitis dénonçant la République
islamique quelques jours plus tard c'est
un automobiliste qui a foncé sur des
manifestants anti-riges devant le lieu
de culte on ne peut plus accepter si
quelqu'un est proche du gouvernement il
faut payer il faut payer pour ça c'est
pour ça que les gens ils décident de se
de montrer leur colère si les tensions
sont si vives c'est que le Canada est
considéré comme un paradis par les
dirigeants du régime iranien selon le
journaliste
en octobre le Premier ministre Justin
Trudeau a d'ailleurs admis la présence
de proches du régime de Téhéran sur le
territoire et promis d’en faire plus
pour les empêcher de s'installer au
Canada des promesses accueillies avec
scepticisme par cet avocat iranien qui
tente d'alerter Ottawa depuis des années
sur le site de son organisme il appelle
maintenant ses compatriotes à lui
envoyer des informations pour dénoncer
les proches du régime qui vivent au
Canada récemment c'est l'ancien chef de
la police de Téhéran qui a été aperçu
dans une salle de sport près de Toronto
de police qui m'a envoyé en prison avec
tellement d'autres étudiants c'est
terrible de voir qu'ils viennent au
Canada en toute liberté ça me rend
malade dit-il c'est ce même ras-le-bol
qui a poussé cette torontoise d'origine
iranienne a enquêté sur les partisans du
régime iranien installé au pays nous
avons accepté de protéger son identité
pour éviter les représailles envers sa
mais en Iran moi je suis qu'un deux on
ne peut pas faire grand-chose légalement
mais on les exposant on peut faire en
sorte que les gens copient avec eux ou
leurs commerces dit-elle Mohamed tâche
de lati s'inquiète des dérives que
pourrait engendrer ces dénonciations en
ligne mais il dit comprendre la colère
de ses compatriotes le mot de la peur a
brisé pour beaucoup des Iraniens ici
selon lui les tensions entre partisans
et opposants au régime ont toujours
existé dans la communauté mais depuis le
début du soulèvement en Iran la peur a
changé de camp et Sandra Williams
Radio-Canada Toronto